let's keep messing with our determinants
to see if we can get more useful results
and they might not be obviously useful
right now but maybe we'll use them later
when we are exploring other parts of
linear algebra so let's say i have some
matrix let's call it matrix x
matrix x is equal to i'll just start
with the three by three case because i
think the two by two case is a bit
trivial actually why don't i just start
with a two by two case let's say matrix
x is a
b and then it has x1
x2
i could have called these c and d but
you'll see why i call them x1 and x2 in
a second and i'll say i have another
matrix let's say matrix y
is identical to matrix x except for this
row
so matrix y is
a
b
y one
and y two
and let's say we have a third matrix z
let's say we have a third matrix z
that's identical to the first two matrix
c's on the first two on the first row
so a b but on the second row it's
actually the sum of the two rows of x
and y so it's going to be this entry is
going to be x1 plus y1 and this entry
right here is y
sorry is
x 2 plus y 2
just like that i want to be very clear z
is not x plus y all of the terms of z
are not the sum of all the terms of x
and y i'm only focusing on one
particular row and this is just a
general theme that you'll see over and
over again and we saw in the last video
and i guess you'll see it here is that
that determinants or finding the
determinants of matrices aren't linear
on matrix operations but they are linear
on operations that you do just to one
row so in this case
everything else is equal except for this
row and z has the same first row is
these guys but second row is the sum of
the second row of these guys so let's
explore how these the determinants of
these guys relate
so the determinant
let me do it in x's color
the determinant of x i'll write it like
that is equal to a
x 2
minus b x 1. i've seen that multiple
times
the determinant of y
is equal to a
y 2 minus b v y1 and the determinant of
z
the determinant of z is equal to
a times x2 plus y2
minus b times x1
plus y1 which is equal to ax2 plus a y2
just distributed the a
minus b x1 minus by one and if we just
rearrange things this is equal to a
let me write it this way this is equal
to a x 2
minus b x 1 so that's that term and that
term let me switch colors
so that's those two guys
and then plus
plus a y 2 minus
b y 1.
now what is this right here that is the
determinant of x
that is the determinant of x and this
right here is the determinant
of y
so there you have it if we have matrices
that are completely identical except for
one row and in this case it's a two by
two matrix so it looks like half of the
matrix and this and z's that row that
we're referring to that's different z's
is the sum of the other two guys rows
then z's disease determinant is the sum
of the other two determinants and this
is a very special case i want to keep
readering it's only works in the case
where this row and only this row is the
sum of this row and this row and the
matrices are identical everywhere else
let me show you the three by three case
and i think it'll make it a little bit
more general and then we'll go to n by n
the n by n is actually on some level the
easiest to do but it's kind of abstract
so i like to save that for the end
so let's redefine
let's redefine all those guys in the
into the three by three case
so let's say that x
is equal to
a b
c
let's just do let's make the third row
the row we're going to use to determine
our determinant a b c
d e
f actually let me do the middle row
because i don't want to make you think
it always has to be the last row so
let's say it's x1
x2
x3 and then you have a d e f
and what's the determinant of x going to
be the determinant
of x
is going to be equal to let's say we're
going along
this row right here that's the row in
question it's going to be equal to we
remember your checkerboard pattern so
it's going to be remember plus minus
plus minus plus you remember all the
rest how it goes so it's going to start
with a minus x1
minus x1 times
times the sub matrix you get rid of that
column that row bcef
b c
e f
then you have plus x2
plus x2 times the sub matrix get rid of
that column that row a c d f
a c
d f and then finally minus x three you
get rid of its row and column you have a
b d e
a
b
d e
now let me define
another matrix y that is identical to
matrix x except for that row
so it's a
b
c
and then down here d e f but that middle
row is different it's y one
y two
and y three
what's the determinant of y going to be
determinant of
y well it's going to be identical to the
determinant of x because all the sub
matrices are going to be the same when
you cross out this row and each of the
columns but the coefficients are going
to be different instead of an x1 you
have a y1 so it's going to be equal to
minus y1 times bc determinant
bce f
plus y 2 times the determinant of a c
d f
minus y 3 times the determinant of a b
d e i think you see where this is going
now i'm going to create another matrix
i'm going to create another matrix z
i'm going to create another matrix z
just like that
that is equal to
it's equal it's identical to these two
guys on the first and third rows a b c
d
e
f
just like that but this row just happens
to be the sum of this row and this row
and when we figured out this determinant
we went along that row you can see that
right there so this row right here is
going to be x1 plus y1 that's its first
term
x2 plus y2 and then you have x3 plus y3
now what's the determinant of z going to
be
well we can go down this row
right there so it's going to be minus
x1 plus y1
times its submatrix get rid of that row
that column you get bcef
you get
b c
e f i think you definitely see where
this is going plus this coefficient plus
x 2 plus y 2 times its sub matrix get
rid of that row that column a c d f
a c
d f
and then you have minus
this guy right here
x 3 plus y 3
times its sub matrix get rid of that
column in row a b d e
a b
d
e
now what do you have right here this is
the determinant of z
this is let me do it in a
this right here is the determinant
of z this thing right here i think you
can see immediately if you were to add
this to this you would get this right
here right because you would have this
coefficient and this coefficient on that
if you added them up you would get minus
x1 plus y1 this guy and this guy add up
to this guy
and then if i were to do this guy and
this guy add up to that guy and let me
do another one
and finally that term plus that term add
up to that term so you immediately see
that the determinant
or hopefully you immediately see
that the determinant of x
the determinant of x
plus the determinant of y
plus the determinant of y
is equal to the determinant of z
is equal to the
determinant the determinant of z so we
did it for the two by two case we just
did it for the three by three case might
as well do it for the end by end case so
we know that it it works but the
argument is identical to this three by
three case and that's good to keep in
your mind because three by three is easy
to visualize and by n is sometimes a
little bit abstract
so let me define let me redefine my
matrices again i'm just going to do the
same thing over again
so i'm going to have a matrix x but it's
an n it's an x it's an n
by n matrix
and let's say
so let me write it this way let's say it
is a 1 1
a 1 2 all the way to a 1 n and there's
some row here let's say that it's
let's say that there's some row here on
row i
let's call this row i right here and
here it is has the terms x1
x2
all the way to xn but then everything
else is just the regular a's so then you
have a let me make this is a21 all the
way to 2a2n and then if you went all the
way down here you would have you would
have a
n1 and you'd go all the way to a and n
so essentially you could imagine our
standard matrix where everything is
defined a but i replaced row i with
certain numbers that are maybe a little
different and i think you'll see where
i'm going now let me define my other
matrix
let me define matrix y
let me define matrix y to be
essentially the same thing this is a11
it's the same a11 this is a12 all the
way to a1n this is a 2 1 we could go all
the way to a 2 n and then on row i
the same row this this is n by n this is
the same n by n if this was 10 by 10
this is 10 by 10. if this is row 7 then
this is row 7 it has different terms
it's identical to matrix x except for
row i in row i it is
y 1
y 2 all the way to y n and then if you
keep going down of course you have a and
1 all the way to
a n n fair enough
now let's say we have a third matrix
let's have a third matrix let me draw it
right here
so you have z
z is equal to i think you could imagine
where this is going
z is identical
z is identical to these two guys except
for row i so let me write that out so z
looks like this you have a 1 1
a 1 2
a 1 2 all the way to a a1n and then you
go down and then row i
happens to be the sum of the row i of
matrix x and mode matrix y so it is
x plus
x1 plus y1 x2 plus y2 all the way to xn
plus
yn
and then you keep going down everything
else is identical a
and 1 all the way to a and n
so all of these matrices are identical
except for row x has a different row i
than rho then matrix y does and rho z is
identical everywhere except its row i is
the sum of this row i and that or y so
it's a very particular case but we can
figure out their determinants so what
are the determinants the determinant
of x the determinant of matrix x and
hopefully you're maybe a bit comfortable
with writing sigma notation we did this
in the last matrix we can go down this
row we can go down
this row right there
and for each of these guys we can say we
can say that this so the determinant is
going to be equal to the sum
the sum let's say we start from j is
equal to
one j is going to be the column so we're
going to go by we take the sum of each
of these terms from j is equal to one to
n
to n and then remember our checkerboard
pattern so we don't know if this is a
positive or negative but we can figure
it out by taking
negative 1
to the i plus j remember this is the ith
row that we're talking about
times
times xj xj is the coefficient
x sub j
times
the sub matrix the sub matrix for
x sub j so if you get rid of this guy's
row and this guy's column what is it
going to be we could say that that's the
same thing as the sub matrix if we
called this guy
let me write it this way if we got rid
of this guy's row in this guy's column
if we had you know just our traditional
matrix where this wasn't replaced if we
just had an a i
a i1 here a i2 this would be its sub
matrix would be the same thing because
we're crossing out this row in this
column
so it would be you know all of these
guys and all these guys down here so it
would be the sub matrix this is a n
minus 1 by n minus 1 matrix would be the
sub matrix for a
i j
and then that's for the first term sorry
the determinant
don't want to lose the determinant there
times the determinant of the sub matrix
a i j and so that's for the first term
and then you're going to add it to the
second term and then you're just going
to keep doing that and that's what this
sigma notation is that's the determinant
of x
now what's the determinant of y
the determinant of y
is equal to
is equal to the sum we can do the same
thing j is equal to 1 to n of negative 1
to the i plus j
each of we're going to take we're going
to go along this row right here
the ith row so we're going to have y
sub j right we're going to start with y
sub 1 then plus y sub 2
times
the determinant of its sub matrix which
is the same as the determinant of this
submatrix when you get rid of that row
and that column for each of these guys
the everything else on the matrix is the
same so a
i j the matrix of a i j
now what is the determinant of z
i'm pretty sure you know exactly where
this is going the determinant this
should be a capital y right there the
determinant of z is equal to
the sum from j is equal to 1
to n
of negative 1 to the i plus j we're
going along this row
but now the coefficients are
x i
sorry x j that's our what we're indexing
along x j
plus y j
and then times its sub matrix which is
the same as these sub matrices
so a
i j
which you might immediately see is the
sum of these two things if i for every
for every j i just summed these two
things up you're having two coefficients
you could have this coefficient and that
coefficient on your on on your a i j
term and then when you add them up you
can factor this guy out and you'll get
this right here
you will get this right here so you get
the determinant of x plus the
determinant of y is equal to the
determinant of z so hopefully that shows
you the general case but i want to make
it very clear this is just for a very
particular scenario where
three matrices are identical except for
on one row and one of the matrices on
that special row just happens to be the
sum of the other two matrices
for that special row and everything else
is identical that's the only time where
the determinant of z not the only time
but that's the only time we can make the
general statement where the determinant
of z is equal to the determinant of x
plus the determinant of y
it's not the case let me write what is
not the case so not
the case not the case
that if
that if let's say z is equal to x plus y
it is not the case that the determinant
of z is necessarily equal to the
determinant of x plus the determinant
determinant
of
y you cannot assume this determinant
operations are not linear on matrix
addition they're linear only on
particular rows getting added anyway
hopefully you found found that vaguely
useful